here's a tricky inequality find the set  of values of X for which 1 divided by x  squared plus 2X minus 3 is less than  zero  to solve this problem notice the  numerator of the fraction is positive so  we need the denominator to be negative  so this is true if and only if x squared  plus 2X minus 3 is less than zero now  Factor this quadratic into X plus 3  multiplied by x minus 1. now let's draw  a number line and mark off the points  negative three and one at these points  the quadratic is equal to zero so we  don't include these points now the  leading term of the quadratic is  positive so we know the parabola will  Point upwards so to look something like  this so to the left of negative 3 will  be positive in between negative three  and one will be negative and above one  will be positive so the range where we  are negative is negative three is less  than x is less than one  and that's the answer